I got hella tattoo job counting I got my
first tattoo when I was 13 I got a
tattoo of my neck my nickname queen was
some music notes and some stars I
covered it up but that's my first one I
had to you hear me cuz everybody my
school they thought it was tugging so
hard
everybody was getting tattoos right yeah
I got a tattoo on the arm and stuff you
feel me they started what rather they
start service doesn't like I don't think
it might make you feeling cuz I'm the
ranking no job anyway even I had always
knew I was gonna make it
even I was planning on it you FEM I was
banking on it and then I had dreads
already so I couldn't let my dreads down
if anyone should so that was always a
treat definitely inspired by Wayne fair
got right on the side you probably can
barely read it but it's definitely safe
here guys I was 15 then I went and got
um confidence on my neck when I was 17 I
remember I was like confidence to
sustain they came wipeout that's when I
when they gotta Ted it and then I when I
got Jesus Teddy then I thought when they
got Jesus I went got a rose on my neck
and then I thought when they got the
rose on my neck I went to put original
Atlanta brave sign on my knee
did I went to put some hard on her back
of my neck and some doves made peace in
love I did the dogs Nicks I when I got
the air for I beat it fresh I'm boys now
when he got my mama Teddy and my mom
made it tough
come on dude
then I wouldn't got this 10 after it's
like a teddy bear but on the inside you
see somebody even so it's basically put
a like don't judge a book by it's cover
you know people could show today one way
and he another side on the inside so I
got that I got these two fathers stars
because I felt like I spent like two
years of my life like in my music career
just like under the table you feel I
felt like they weren't paying attention
so I went to got two stars Chris Brown
inspired even we see the first guy his
tattoos with the Stars and the X's on
the middle whatever and then I wanted
got dream you look at Chris Brown tan he
got a tetanus a frame I when I got
dreaming I used to be real being on TV
you know is a huge inspiration so when I
got the elephant where the X's on it the
alien cuz I'm out of here
and I went got peace in love a lot of
people while Sprunt a thought of a piece
on a time that but it's really just a
piece huh yeah I want to put my beat
that's my label put up I'll be on my
elbow
yeah it's done on the east side when he
got the three roses on the east I got a
you can't really see it but I got a
spaceship right cuz I told you I'm out
of spaceship right here I got on speak
no evil hear no evil see no evil got
that side when I was like 18
I definitely got this tattoo when I was
18 I remember no one's saying is greater
than another oh I wouldn't got the
carton jacquees on the back of my arm
that's like the 18 year old me on the
back you can't receive it as a cartoon
it was just artists in Atlanta
his pictures used to cost so much I was
like I only want a picture to drop me a
little cartoon and I just get it like
this he did it from I when it got framed
kills when I was 17
that's right here Fame kills his fame
can't kill him if you let it
so yeah I got the music no right here
this is my label right fyb I told you I
got it on my elbow earlier on when they
got it on my hand later freshman boys
over here on this hand that's my drummer
got my girl right there Daisy snow a
leader of the family and I put a diamond
right there on top of it because you
know what diamond is Everlast
I got the k2 tattoo right here that's
where I'm from right here just like
everything I feel like I grew up around
indicator on my hands it's a you see
like the piece on the heart the money
sign the pistol there 40 to 75 quarter
of Monday
that's really where I grew up he's never
invited sponsors any power to this story
this right here family forever me and my
whole family got this like my auntie
uncle everybody family with the forever
side
when I started smoking weed Mickey Mouse
is always my favorite character I was
young but I had four making on my level
so I wanted to put Mickey with a gas
mask he look a lot hot for this I get i
when he got my angel Raya guardian angel
right to help me always if I wanted got
my nephew Ted it little ray my nephew he
worked there I keep Mary where we you
know I'm his hero
I got another rose and I uh you know he
I always the austere tonight but he said
I'll see everything so when he got it
out cuz I see everything I got a star on
my ear I went to got that in like the
ninth grade it's a star right
entitlement yeah I got a damn it
right yeah think I'm on the right side
he's a diamond and I got my grandmother
name says Daisy and right here I don't
know you can see it but right here like
oh my she gave me strength and Curt and
I got a Rosie that's my mama you know my
cheek right here mean long life probably
does not listen thinking system I got
under here I got it two angels and the
wings you see the wings are there the
two angels up there I got some body tats
a couple of I really got the Kings
symbol tattooed on my leg I been had it
I got wrong 18 so I don't think the king
she just came up yeah I got C I'm teddy
cash money
I'm gonna put some fire on it now cuz
I'm on fire I linked with Cash Money
Berman had came today I wanted to
footwear Ridge again it's so rich on the
corner young thought was donating real
big I reached out to court who was
reached on call his father he introduced
me to burn man he was wit bourbon at the
time I made the car are you feeling me
Rodriguez is my first name feeling this
right here means tricorder
it's three things that you can't untie
me and my sister's got it my favorite
tattoo is probably my brother
of course I'm loving I mean my
grandmother's my mother my 4b tattoo my
long long life tattooing my rosy days of
tattoos obviously although it was this
girl named Kim she worked in this little
store named wish she's not my big sister
you know Sam but she was flies here he's
had some flies tattoos and that rises
like that me they attached it was hard
but I wasn't Frankie's tell he's gonna
get tatted they was Ted it already I was
like nah I can't get tatted like that
I'm gonna burn myself I like I always
won't ruin a growth I will people see me
one of y'all with this tattooed and I
come back
other times I want to just flip my body
in every year I look the same
yeah I still got a couple room on my
body god bless
[Music]